oh wow
wow
and when chris rock gets slapped his
younger brother tony will have something
to say about it it's the family business
the the johnsons have q-tips the
firestones have tires the rocks have
jokes and now after the slap heard
around the world a source is confirming
to e.t chris and will have yet to
reconcile that was a
greatest night in the history of
television first let's get you up to
speed on oscar's night will smith
unexpectedly stormed the stage and
smacked chris
oh wow why well chris made a joke about
will's wife jada pinkett smith jada i
love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it
all right
following the altercation the king
richard starr won the oscar but didn't
mention chris in his speech i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
this is a beautiful moment i'm not
crying for winning an award it's not
it's not about winning an award for me
it's about being able to shine light on
all of the people the day after will had
a change of heart and shared an apology
to the comedian directly on instagram
writing i was out of line and i was
wrong i'm embarrassed and my actions
were not indicative of the man i want to
be but the bond between chris and his
brother tony you could say it's rock
solid and tony he says it's not enough
it all went down on twitter a fan asked
tony who's also a comedian if he
approves of will's apology tony's
response
no then tony addressed when diddy said
this
okay will and chris we're gonna solve
that like family at the gold party
okay but right now we're moving on with
love
everybody make some noise
so when a twitter fan asked tony if
diddy was lying when he said that tony
replied a simple
yup chris is just he's just chris to us
it's like like you know when he comes
home he's not a celebrity he's just a
skinny guy that we used to beat up all
the time now the grown-up star himself
has yet to publicly speak out about the
slap but e.t has learned more about what
happened after the big show a source
tells et that chris hit up an after
party explaining he didn't want to let
the incident with will ruin his night
out with friends chris was still in
shock by the whole incident and didn't
want it to become a whole thing at the
party so he didn't talk too much about
it and it seems like the actor is moving
forward just fine days later he arrived
in boston on tuesday for a stop on his
comedy tour and a source tells e.t chris
was working out wednesday morning at a
gym by his hotel turns out ticket sales
surged since the incident and are now
sold out but the source also adds that
extra security has been added for his
show in beantown you make sure as much
as you can make sure and one thing's for
sure chris's community has his back our
source says many big names in hollywood
have reached out to them and are
checking in
[Music]
you